the space race is so different now it
used to be a two-horse race between the
United States and the Soviet Union now
there's a long list of space-faring
Nations and companies uh it's not just
about the flag planting anymore it's
about the science there's money to be
made and our everyday lives are being
affected by what's going on in space Our
Lives depend on it so to discuss the how
and the why I'm joined by an expert
panel we've got Melissa Thorpe uh the
boss of Spaceport Cornwall now just days
away from launching a rocket from the
runway of Nuki airport we've got Lord
Reese Martin Reeser a world-renowned
cosmologist and the astronomer Royal a
post I read created by Charles II no
less to map the night sky and is it true
you get 100 pounds a year still don't
even get that you don't even get that or
bad luck I think you're going to go and
demand it and also from New Mexico are
joined by Mike Moses there we are Mike
with with the unity in in the background
there your your Mothership uh he is
president of Virgin Galactic who's on a
countdown uh to the company's first
commercial flights for space tourists
early next year fingers crossed Mike and
we'll also be going live shortly uh to a
NASA astronaut and that's going to be
really exciting but a quick reminder
about the questions you can submit them
by scanning the QR code that was on the
card on your seat and if you're watching
on TV or online you can submit your
questions on Twitter using the hashtag
Big Ideas live 22. but Melissa let's
start with you
I mean goodness me it's exciting to a
thinker a rocket launch from the UK
yeah I mean it is still a bit surreal
eight years ago we used to get laughed
at but who's laughing now
um we're very close to launching for the
first time ever from UK soil
um from Cornwall and it's just been such
a roller coaster ride
um but it's all coming to fruition now
down in Cornwall and and we're really
just proud of what this is about to do
for the UK but let's be clear this isn't
a NASA style vertical launch to space
you've got some other idea tell us about
what you're going to be doing down in
Newquay yeah absolutely so we're working
with Virgin orbits so Mike's with our
version Galactic we're with Virgin orbit
we're not being sponsored by the
complete coincidence I I don't represent
them but um our Spaceport is launching
our first launch with them and that
basically uses a Boeing 747 that's been
modified to carry a giant 70-foot
two-stage rocket under one of its wings
basically what it will do is go up part
way to space where it deploys that
rocket mid-air and that rocket goes into
space
and uh let's talk to you Mike I mean
you're taking a slightly different idea
I mean you're also using a plane but
you're again going to be taking
passengers uh not cargo not the the
satellites that Melissa will be taking
up in the first launch from Cornwall
yeah that's right we have a Mothership
that's custom built uh called VMS Eve uh
and it carries spaceship Unity which is
behind me here uh which is where our
pilots and our passengers fly so uh we
we take a ride up to about 50 000 feet
and release the spaceship uh light the
rocket motor from there and take folks
uh up on a suborbital journey to space
so they get to go experience uh a few
minutes of microgravity get out of their
seats uh look out the window see the
earth below them The Thin Blue Line of
the atmosphere and the Blackness of
space uh before they come back and land
at the runway they took off from so a
really great Human Experience uh for
people to be able to see the Earth from
above
so from satellites to to space tourists
you're getting a good sense there
already of of how people are seizing the
opportunities of space and Martin do you
think that that humans should be going
to to space at all
well I'm old enough to have remembered
Neil Armstrong once more step really
inspirational and of course at that time
I thought that long before today there
have been footprints on Mars but of
course it was 1972 at the last people
returned from the Moon and since that
time humans have done no more than going
to low earth orbits but of course space
has developed hugely as you said we
defend it every day for Sat Nav
Communications weather forecasting Etc
and of course for me as an astronomer we
benefited usually from instruments up
above the blurring of the Earth's
atmosphere most recently of course the
James web telescope so space has been
very exciting but of course the other
thing that's happened is that robots
have advanced hugely and so uh maybe
we'll come back later but perhaps I can
advertise my book called the end of
Astro notes co-authored with a friend
called Don Goldsmith and here we argue
that the Practical need for sending
humans into space
is more or less eliminated because
robots can do the exploring
with enough Ai and they can fabricate
big structures in space so my line is
that space travel is uh
as an adventure
and should be left to the private sector
I don't think if I was an American I
wouldn't want any public money to go
towards uh NASA's uh humans-based Life
program uh that's because it's of no
practical value now and also if NASA
does something it's very expensive
because they've got to be very
risk-averse
the space shuttle was launched 135 times
it crashed twice each of those crashes
was a big trauma and
that's a less two percent failure rate
and they tried hard to cut that down so
my line is that we don't need humans in
space for practical purposes but let's
leave it to the billionaires who can
launch people prepared to accept much
higher risks than
even two percent
people like hang gliders and around the
world balloonists and people like that
and um maybe someday people go to Mars
even with a one-way ticket
um Elon Musk musk says he wants to die
on Mars but not on impact and he's 51
now so 40 years from now he might do
that well let's let's come back to the
the space billionaires uh in a minute
but let me just challenge you on on the
value of sending human scientists to
Mars the robots the rovers are fantastic
but it does need some human operator
back here to help decide which rocks to
head for and they're doing that on the
basis of a two-dimensional screen isn't
it not better to send a human who can
walk the dust tap the Rocks decide where
to drill yeah well that's certainly true
today
um the um perseverance uh uh vehicle on
Mars
um has enough AI to be able to work his
way around obstacles and all that but it
can't do the geology but I would argue
that long before we think of sending
people to Mars which would be 20 years
from now
um the AI will be able to do the geology
too just as well as a human and of
course at vastly less cost because
sending people to Mars a six-month
journey is much much harder
and that's more expensive and more risky
than sending them to the moon so 20
years from now I think the AI will be
able to do most of the science
Mike in in New Mexico and his space
tourists for now in near-earth orbit do
you have Ambitions to uh not yet in the
near in orbit do you have Ambitions to
go into to orbit and perhaps even Beyond
yeah sure I think uh you know uh uh with
with due respect to the astronomer Royal
the the the exploration by robots is is
definitely a less risky thing but I
think he really diminish The Experience
feedback the question I always got when
I was at Nasa and here at Virgin
Galactic you know why do we send people
to space and and I think at the heart of
it there's a fundamental uh human nature
and while it is risky and expensive uh
it is very Noble and it gives
inspiration uh and a real purpose and so
you know here at Virgin Galactic we're
going to try to let a lot of folks go to
to look uh sub orbit and be able to see
the Earth uh and experience space travel
in just a small slice but I think that
has if you if you jump ahead 10 years 20
30 right the chance to really transform
Society to where we view space and space
exploration as part of our core fiber uh
pretty soon everybody should hopefully
know someone who's been to space if
everything goes well pretty soon
everybody will have the chance to to go
to space and when I say pretty soon you
know I'm talking a decade or so two
decades right but but think of the
transformation that will occur just like
InterContinental air travel transformed
the way people work here on Earth I do
believe that space travel as an
inspiration and as an experience really
will help our society transform and
drive to the Future on the research side
right uh there is a little aspect of
space research is one of those areas
where you kind of have to build your
experiment and hand it to somebody else
whether it's a robot or an astronaut
trained up on the space station and uh
and while they're highly trained and
they're very skilled right your time on
your experiment is very limited so you
actually could potentially while AI is
making great advances you can actually
reduce some of the automation if you're
there with it so in a sub-orbital craft
like like ours on VSS Unity you can have
the chance to go up and tend to the
experiment yourself and therefore it
doesn't have to be as complicated it
could be cheaper and you can go fly it
more often so I think there's a there
there's a knee in both sides of that
curve that need to be understood but I
think there's great potential for The
Human Experience as well
thanks Mike I mean Melissa and I think
it's what you're doing down in Cornwall
is really exciting and you you've got
satellites in the in the first Rockets
but do you see the day where you will be
launching tourists from from Newquay
airport as well
yeah we can ask that question quite a
lot
um we're focused solely just on
satellites at the moment that is
difficult enough you know our friends in
the US have been doing it for 50 years
and it's taken them that long to get to
the point where we're now sending
tourists up so I think you know a bit of
a ways to go here in the UK
um I couldn't sit here and say that that
would never be part of you know what
could potentially happen in the future
where an airport we're a port and a port
does things it it brings people in and
out and Cargo in and out so I can
imagine one day there there will be an
opportunity for us to look at that but
at the minute we're just focused on
satellites we'll get that right first
um but saying that we have partnered
with Sierra space who are looking at the
Dream Chaser and as a return Landing
site from space and that will be crude
so that in itself and I think you know
there's there's slightly the
connotations about space tourism but
human space flight is um is something
that we're all interested in because
there's so so much value as Mike has
said you know to what that could bring
to us back here on Earth by sending
people into space it was fascinating
being down at Spaceport Cornell recently
it was for there was a lot of people
down there a lot of the space industry
from the UK were all making their tracks
down to see what you're doing and it
really just showed the health of the
industry here in the UK how important it
is 47 000 people uh are employed by the
industry it's worth 16.5 billion dollars
a billion pounds a year but at the
moment although we're really good at
building satellites we're having to
launch them from as far away as New
Zealand exactly and that's the whole
reason that I'm sat here is that we
build a large majority of the world's
small satellites in this country every
single one of them goes overseas to
launch and that's not just a market
opportunity but also if you think of it
from a geopolitical perspective but also
from an environmental perspective if we
can control the way that we launch our
own satellites it gives us a lot more
opportunity to create you know a more
responsible and ethical kind of launch
that goes on to create economic Valley
to the UK as well so it's for us that's
that surprise is is creating a launch
capability that supports the UK
Marketplace but doing in a way that we
feel proud of Martin are you excited
about what's happening here in the UK
now with rocket launches and uh
satellites views of satellites and so on
I think it's great and um you'll be
launching very soon six or seven very
useful satellites so that's great
um as regards that uh sending people
um I agree it's inspirational and this
is going to become fairly routine for
low earth orbits but if I were to offer
virgin advice I would say they should
not use the phrase space tourism they
should call it space adventure which is
not ever going to be as routine as uh
flying in an aircraft and if you call it
space tourism if you forget that
impression and the first accident will
kill it all off whereas if you say it's
space adventure then just as people
don't stop mountaineering when someone
gets killed on the mountain then they
won't stop going into space so I think
it should be presented as an adventure
and paid for by the people who go and
not by taxpayers well I think we better
bring in in Mike here uh should we be
calling them space tourists is that
okay well actually you know that that
phrase uh yeah no I don't think that
phrase uh truly captures it I think uh
Adventures good uh future astronauts uh
explores whatever term you want to use
the uh the point of it is a
transformational experience uh by
traveling to space whether you're going
to go on a suburbital journey uh for a
short duration you go up on a short
orbital Mission you go to a space
station or a commercial space station
right all of those I think uh have that
same flavor of of uh transformational
experience for you as a as a human as a
person right and then the ability to
come back uh back to Earth with that
effect the uh they call it the overview
effect when you go to space and you're
able to look back on the earth uh you
come back a little bit changed with your
perspective you you see the fragility of
the atmosphere you recognize uh the lack
of borders and the Big Blue Marble what
the phrases right that we're all
astronauts on spaceship earth right and
you kind of recognize that a little bit
and it does change you
um and and I think the more folks that
get that perspective you know we're
seeing a huge shift here recently with
just the awareness in in Social and
economic impacts of climate and the
environment and needing to protect that
and take care of it right and and I view
the the act of being able to go and
experience space as kind of a drive it
home to get to see that so not only does
space let you launch the satellites that
let you observe the Earth and see the
climate change and the effect but being
able to witness it with your own eyes uh
helps you kind of transform the pieces
of the world you affect directly so I do
think uh it's not so much tourism but I
think it really is a practical purpose
Mike you couldn't have set up our NASA
astronaut any better let's bring in the
professional this is Nicole stock former
NASA astronaut uh two space flights 104
days in space one spacewalk and a
spectacular spacesuit there in the
background and Nicole uh what's going on
uh well I you know nice to be here and I
appreciate hearing all the comments from
everyone
um and the spacesuit behind me is part
of its name is exploration it's part of
a program we do at the space for Art
Foundation working with kids all over
the world uniting a planetary community
of children through the awe and wonder
of space exploration and the healing
power of Art
so you're really inspiring people
through your own travels in in space and
Mike was talking there about the
overview effect that that feeling that
people who are looking down on the earth
get that connection with Humanity that
love of the planet and you you saw that
yourself didn't you and you tried to
express it you were the first person to
use watercolors in space and I think
you've actually got the painting with
you let's let's hold it up and tell me
why you tried to express what you were
seeing
well here it is
um
so it's a it's a painting of a little
chain of islands I saw on the northern
coast of Venezuela called Las rocas and
I remember looking out the window and
um and as I would do every time I looked
out the window just being in awe
surprised by what I was going to see the
overwhelming
beauty of um of our planetary home and I
remember thinking wow it looks like
somebody had reached down with a
paintbrush and painted a wave on the
ocean and it became my favorite picture
from space and so I decided to use
that for my inspiration to paint while I
was there but it has also inspired the
work I'm doing myself and trying to
share the space flight experience in a
way that
does just what what you guys are talking
about tries to communicate this
um significance of our role as crewmates
here on our planetary spaceship just
this realization that we live on a
planet it's a big one and I know in
hearing the words from Martin as well I
think it works the other way too if we
open ourselves up to it if we
like think about the fact that every day
we walk outside we're standing on a
planet and when we look up at this blue
sky that seems to go on forever
remind ourselves that it's just this
Veil fin protective layer wrapping
around us just like the hull of our
spaceship and
um there's something about people humans
experiencing that that I think
um and I can say for me
um for sure is has a transformational
effect has a not just who I experienced
it wasn't that awesome but it puts
something into you where you really want
to come back to earth and take action as
a result of it as well and I believe
every one of these people that's
experiencing it through uh the the
flights that are available now
commercially are coming back with that
same kind of resolve and I was thinking
about this this week now that uh Artemis
program is underway we're going back to
the Moon which is really exciting but
those images taken by Iran looking back
at our tiny fragile Blue Marble against
that black curtain of space I mean those
kinds of images taken by the Apollo
Astronauts really helped to give birth
to the environmental movement back in
the 60s and then 70s it is a thing isn't
it
yeah I absolutely believe it I mean like
Martin said too I
um I had I had these Vivid memories of
watching you know Neil and Buzz walking
on the moon knowing that Mike Collins
was orbiting it and you know going
outside and and looking at the moon and
being even at you know seven years old
understanding that that was a really
extraordinary thing and then these
images that are coming back now that are
kind of allowing us to reflect on Apollo
but looking forward to what Artemis will
bring I think they're showing us that
we're always looking for that connection
to ourselves it's part of why we as
humans want to get out there you know
and explore our planetary home from a
totally new vantage point and I love
those pictures because
um whether it's taken from you know an
Orion spacecraft or as it will be from
humans again when we're traveling there
oh my gosh
um we we really I don't think we get any
better sense of who and where we are in
space together and the significance of
this place in space this this very
special planetary home that we have
but having seen the the world's most
powerful ever Rocket taking off from uh
from Kennedy I mean what would you give
to be on on the rocket to to the moon
and walk there one day as let's face it
no oh my God no no woman has walked on
the moon yet but that is the ambition of
our team is to make sure that a woman
will be there a person of color will be
there uh and and the hope is that that
will be in there you know I have a very
good friend Stephanie Wilson who would
meet both of those criteria I'd love to
see her walking on the moon and I've
already told her she should be packing
me in her luggage with her to go but you
would love to go you'd love to walk on
the moon would you
absolutely and I think that you know the
moon it's like it's like our partner in
space right um we all have a connection
to it in some way I think that
um I would absolutely love to walk on
the moon I live I look forward at least
to living vicariously through my friends
and others that will and
um and knowing that by establishing our
presence there you know in a more
permanent sense settling there in a
permanent way will allow us to take
advantage and and I say that in a
positive way of the resources available
on the moon for us to lift some of the
industry that we have on Earth off the
planet and into space all for the
benefit of life on Earth and as we take
those you know those steps
um you know those six to however many
months it'll be heading towards Mars we
can do that from the Moon and uh um
I don't know in a much more efficient
way than we can lifting ourselves off
the planet and I think that's part of
the plan as well
so let's if we obviously have all eyes
on on you Nicole and you must be really
popular parties just reliving your
experiences in space but let's bring you
into the wider wider discussion I mean
uh Martin I mean when you hear people
like uh Nicole speaking and they are
there is something about seeing space
exploration through human eyes isn't
there it is an inspiration for for a new
generation we saw that with Tim Peake
and and the work that the UK space
agency did to try and get kids if not
into space certainly into stem subjects
science and maths
um yes but I think lots of people are
fascinated by the pictures of deep space
sent back by probes of the outer planets
and of course by telescopes like James
Webb of very very distant nebulae and
galaxies and things that's inspirational
and one of the most exciting things
discovered by astronomers in the last 10
or 20 years uh as most people probably
know is that most of the stars in the
sky are orbited by retinos of planets
just like the sun's orbited by the earth
and the familiar planets and we're
starting to study these and one thing
that will be really inspirational is a
long-term goal and I discuss it in this
book is that um
by 2068
some descendant of Jay's web a much
bigger and more powerful telescope than
that will be able to give us an image of
an Earth-like planet
orbiting another star
perhaps with life on it
why do I say 2068 that's Centenary of
the famous uh um uh picture taken by Ed
Anders which you mentioned which was
indeed very inspirational showing the uh
Earth's fragile biosphere but a hundred
years after that
then we may have an inspirational
picture
taken of a planet like the Earth
orbiting another star we can never go
there but it'll still be inspirational
and will tell us more about life in the
universe
we you were talking earlier on how
public money should not be used for
human exploration that it should be
private uh companies like SpaceX I mean
look I mean throw this out to the the
panel just wave at me uh if you're
remote but how important do you think it
is for companies like SpaceX to be
playing such a really big important role
in Exploration what they're doing now
the risks they take the rapid
acceleration that they're making in
technology that is pushing forward the
possible
anybody Mike come on you used to work in
NASA and uh yeah go for it
yeah yeah I think uh I think it is
really important we're seeing a real
transformation and inflection if you
just step back uh a decade or two right
the commercial satellite launch industry
when shuttle when space shuttle was
formed right the idea was we didn't need
any more Expendable Rockets all
satellites launches could occur on the
space shuttle here in the United States
and and the Challenger accident really
revealed that to be a pretty bad plan no
diversity uh in in launch capability uh
and it sparked a revolution Arianne uh
stepped right out into the commercial
Market the rest of the industry
responded quickly uh and now we see a
plethora of commercial satellite launch
capability uh around the world the same
thing is now happening with human uh
launch capability uh and pretty soon I
think the next thing on the horizon will
be commercial destination so it's one
thing for the transportation up and down
uh to space but now uh can you have a
commercial destination that you go to
the space station the International
Space Station is a an absolute Marvel of
engineering uh and a really great
internet National Partnership but as as
Martin is saying right it's a government
program
um and I think we're right on the cusp
of seeing commercial uh destinations to
go in low earth orbit uh and then soon
High Earth Urban and Beyond uh into near
lunar space so I think with that
transformation we'll really see yet
another explosion in the private sector
of how we innovate uh and and advance
and open opportunities to all and so
with uh there's definitely a role for
the government right there setting big
missions setting big priorities helping
with large technological development and
then helping regulate uh not only to
keep things safe and steady but a little
bit of also let that Innovation occur I
think that's a great partnership between
the governments around the world and
Private Industry around the world we're
talking today about who owns the future
isn't there a danger that if
billionaires have Commander space it's
them who owns the future it's not us and
our stake through publicly funded space
travel
Martin yes
um uh well we can share them on
um as Risk Takers and I hope that by the
end of a century there will be a small
community on Mars and we could cheer
them on but I think they should be
privately funded
um uh I think that isn't a mistake that
we've made with social media that we
have very little control about the
moderation we just trust it to the
people who own the companies well yes
but that's where everyone cares about
that everyone uses social media uh
whereas I don't think that the same is
is true here but I mean uh I'd like to
say that the private sector has been
hugely important I mean um uh SpaceX
um of course it's a new rocket I need to
be tested soon called Starship is the
size of Artemis but much much cheaper
because even the first stage is going to
be reusable I think that's right so uh
our Artemis is using
old technology by the standard of um of
what SpaceX can do and that's why it's
so expensive and indeed I'm not just
being cynical
um the article on the topic in last
week's Economist headlined white
elephant in space in reference to uh
Artemis because it is old technology
that's why it's been very expensive but
uh um the space
um X and the private companies have
really made huge improvements and
brought down the cost and I think we
should all welcome that
thank you so much right now look it's
your turn let's ask some questions I
think let's let's give the audience uh a
chance here so a reminder you can submit
your questions by scanning the QR code
if you're watching on TV online you can
submit your questions on Twitter using
the hashtag Big Ideas live uh22 uh has
anybody got any questions
we've got a question here on the front
row see if you'd like to stand up
it's amazing being hand meeting you guys
in person I just my question was is what
would people in the space industry
especially students who are interested
in joining the space industry what kind
of advice would you give them especially
for the UK to join the UK space agency
and just general Space Industries within
the UK
Melissa go and take that one yeah that's
definitely something that's happening
right now with us
um and I'm very lucky to be going into
schools and universities almost on a
daily basis and speaking to students and
launches very as we we've talked about
space is exciting it's inspirational
launch especially is massively
inspirational we're now just starting to
see that here in the UK going into
places that have never imagined they'd
be in the space industry really deprived
areas of Cornwall for instance and
they're being suddenly told like space
is happening on their doorstep and for
us it's a responsibility to to get them
excited then show them the pathways into
the industry and for me the best thing
that we could do for the space industry
is not narrow it down to just the space
industry it crosses absolutely
everything all Industries now use space
in some way or another
um so for me my main message to anybody
interested is you know you can get
involved in whatever you're interested
in there's so many amazing programs out
there of that UK space agency put on
that UK space that the satellite
applications catapult put on
um it you know there's so many out there
and it's not just necessarily for people
interested in the space industry and
that's what's so exciting about it
um but yeah obviously come work for us
if you want that'd be great we need more
women Okay so we've got another question
from Dave on Twitter how do we justify
the emissions of space travel stroke
tourism given there's no feasible Planet
B should we not use these immense
resources and human Intelligence on
solving problems on Earth First I'm
turning to you Mike
yeah I think uh you know as I mentioned
a little bit earlier some of the and you
did two times right some of the first
awareness of the impact on the planets
uh from every industry and people in
general uh came from those uh Apollo
missions where we first saw the the Blue
Marble uh and then all the satellite
launches and the observation satellites
that have been up there uh doing science
and research specifically on on the
environment so I think space is what
enables that in the first place and so
we shouldn't diminish the contribution
it makes but but obviously as
responsible uh stewards of the planet we
also need to look at our own impact upon
it uh and so I think it's it's important
to be uh you have to be on both sides of
that equation and do so responsibly so
for example uh here at Virgin Galactic
we've designed our ship one of the
reasons we went with an air launch uh
technology is that it is fully reusable
and I don't just mean reusable 10 or 20
times I mean 500 or a thousand times
right these ships are built uh for a
five or ten year Lifetime and we can get
hundreds and hundreds of missions out of
them there's a few components that need
to be replaced we can work on the
sustainability there the impact we have
on the ground can also be worked on
right so we never want to stop but I
think it's important to recognize uh you
have to weigh the value as well as the
impact of what you're doing so I think
we see a a global surgeons in attention
on this and I think we all plan to be
good stewards of the the planet that we
want to go uh explore just briefly
Melissa because I know space
sustainability is really important to
you in Cornwall isn't it space for good
is your thing yeah space for good is our
purpose and it's building on exactly
what Mike just said but you know our
issue with the industry as it's gone on
is space has always been quite secretive
it's not been very transparent and
that's something I think that
fundamentally needs to change as more
commercial businesses come in but more
public become engaged in the industry
you know we're becoming multi-planetary
species we need all of you to be
involved in that conversation so for us
it's really important that we first of
all start with transparency so what is
the car carbon impacts and that's really
difficult because a lot a lot of people
have been asked that question before not
a lot of launch operators have been
asked what your carbon impact is what
happens when the stages fall into the
sea those big questions have not really
been massively researched or understood
or the impact on the atmosphere as
something goes through it so that's what
we're trying to fundamentally understand
as Mike said air launch is a lot less
impactful but we're not going to just
stop there we want to look at you know
how do we look holistically across life
cycle to decrease that impact so that
when we're launching these incredible
Technologies we're not adding to the
problem
and we got a question from Anthony Baker
Anthony where are you
just wait from the microphone we'll get
one to you and then you can ask your
question to the panel just stand so we
can see you that's it hello thank you
um so the European Union has a a space
program called Copernicus which is Earth
observation looking at the Earth
uh the UK is likely to pull out of that
system uh releasing hundreds of millions
of pounds what would the panel do with
that money for the UK space agency
Martin
hmm
well let's say this is one of the
downsides of brexit that although
fortunately we are in the scientific
program of Esa we are not in the
applications programs uh like uh
Copernicus and Galileo and this is this
is bad news
um I think we um uh need to spend the
money if we can't revive it on other
environmental uh exploration
um
preferably from space but also doing
more on the ground and because if if I
can um uh go back to what was said
earlier
um I think that um the impression of the
Earth from space has had a positive
effect of making people care more about
the environment
um but uh it it doesn't
produce very much if people may worry
that these Rockies pollute the Earth but
each rocket I guess is not too different
for one flight of a jumbo jet so that's
not big but um thinking about
um the environment
um I I do disagree very much with the
musk and people in talking about
um
uh
escaping the Earth's Problems by sending
millions of people to Mars I think
that's a dangerous delusion we've got to
focus on solving these problems here on
Earth and uh it's um a Doddle to do
those compared to terraforming Mars for
those we know it's it's very difficult
but I think
as part of that then we need to um
engage with the science and of course if
we can't have Copernicus which is very
sad for the UK then we should must
develop other areas I mean for instance
to give one example
um I think the UK could lead in computer
modeling of climate change I know um
there's a famous uh uh space artist
called Tim Palmer in Oxford who talks
about a CERN for climate change which
would have big computers to do far
better modeling of climate change so um
there's something we can do on the
European scale even if you can't be part
of Copernicus
thank you for that question Anthony so
uh Luca on Twitter asks are there plans
to colonize the moon in the next five
years well Nicole you must be pretty
tapped into what NASA does these days
and do you think we should be going to
the moon and colonize it
well I think we should be going to the
moon and settling it um I don't know
that I'd use the word colonizing but
um
yeah I think there's I think there's
purpose in it I think there is plans for
it
um I'll have my fingers crossed that
those people are making those first
steps in the next five years that would
be a wonderful
uh I think very meaningful follow-on to
this um Artemis one flight that's going
on right now and
um I you know I I look at this like part
of part of the steps to the answers to
the the earlier questions as well
um about why space why not
here when um in reality all of that
we're doing in space is ultimately about
here had the opportunity to participate
in Cope 26 last year where after doing
some research
um discovered to my surprise even that
over 70 percent of the data we need to
like measure the vital signs of of our
planet are coming to us from space and
um these public-private Partnerships
that we have going on right now are the
things both through the you know the
public money and the private money that
are leading us in a much
um I think in an accelerated fashion to
be able to use that data to solve our
planetary challenges but also to help us
um travel you know as humans further
from Earth
um one day I hope it's not impossible
Martin for us to be looking at those
other planets around those different
Suns as uh as possible homes for us and
kind of that interplanetary very Star
Trek future if you will and I think this
this position of positioning of
ourselves on the moon
um really is one of going to be one of
the greatest steps for us lifting our
lifting ability our launch ability off
of Earth and solving a big part of what
that problem might be by actually taking
us to other places in space from the
surface or the orbit of the moon
thanks Nicole just another one on on
Twitter Jason Stone my daughter would
like to ask what would it take to make a
rocket electric and not so reliant on
fossil fuels
you're a dreamer Martin
do you think that could be done
well of course uh the trouble with
electric power as we know from attempts
to have electric Aviation is that uh
batteries are very heavy uh so I think
it's going to be very hard uh to have an
alternative to uh what we now have uh to
provide the big thrust for launching a
rock people do talk about space lifts
don't know that these taken reasonably
serious there's some way you might be
able to have people going up and down to
orbit using some kind of lift system
well future is of course space elevator
where you have the power on the ground
because of course the trouble is that uh
the rocket when you launch it is way
down by the fuel which weighs a lot more
than the actual cargo and so when I
could get around that but that's a huge
technology you want to have this uh
space elevator 20 000 Miles High out to
the geostation orbit so that's hard um
but I think it's hard to substitute for
the high thrust you need to launch but
course some nuclear power can be used to
provide a small
amounts of power for a long time and or
already so I've got rtgs have been used
on deep space missions and so I think
that's a feasible but uh I defer to the
experts on on the possibilities for uh
nuclear power in space for
um Mike do you think you can ever see
nuclear power use being used on on your
kind of craft
uh you know I I think the the weight
issue and the thrust issue is really
like Martin said a huge challenge so I
think once you're in space you have
those options open up for you uh but to
get out of the gravity well of Earth I
think uh for for at least the first year
but future uh the chemical propulsion
systems are kind of where we're limited
to uh until we have a massive uh
technological breakthrough and the focus
on reusability and and lowering the cost
of excess I think we see better uh
better better Technologies there I think
on the ground side certainly the chance
to apply electrics uh and renewable
energy sources is is a wonderful thing
uh but for the actual Act of
transporting out of the gravity well I
think we're uh no pun intended stuck for
a little while
and another one on Twitter and I think
this one's for you uh Melissa and it
relates to space debris
um you know with a there's a risk of a
Cascade Event we're sending so many
um Rockets up now uh that there is a
danger of a collision and I guess
you need to think as we're making space
even more accessible with Spaceport
Cornwall and we've got one in uh two in
Scotland uh which are hoping to come on
on stream next year all of those taking
up multiple satellites space is getting
pretty crowded yeah and again going back
to a responsible launch as a gateway to
space it is a responsibility to look at
you know the the Technologies and the
satellites you're launching to space
what happens at their end of life and
it's a it's a huge Topic in the industry
as well as in the general public which
is fantastic because eight years ago
when I first started in this industry
and I sat down at a conference and you'd
hear all these incredible ideas about
how to mitigate against space debris
catching it with magnets or Nets but
they weren't getting funded
um and they weren't getting the
investment to get off the ground
literally and that's changing and that
is really down to political interest as
well as the public and you know we get
these questions probably the top five
question I get all the time so you're
starting to see that change and you're
starting to see startups with really
incredible Technologies for this
um starting to get funded so on our
first launch in a few weeks we have a
company called space Forge their startup
out of Cardiff and they're doing
something called inorbit manufacturing
they're looking at reasonability of
satellites as well you know that's just
the start of them and they're getting
Venture Capital at involved and then it
goes to regulations and we kind of
touched on it earlier there's not really
been an illness on any company to clean
up their orbit or to clean up their
products once it comes to end of life
and I think again that's something
that's changing so our regulations with
the UK space agency they're looking at
an end-of-life policy deorbiting you
know what what happens to your satellite
you know what these small satellites
going up that might only have you know
five to ten years of a lifespan you know
we need to start to consider this and
put the onus back on the companies
um to clean up their their technology so
it doesn't cause you know as we send
more humans to space any issues
one last question from the audience
Andrew Karen where are you
at the back there just hang on a minute
we'll get a microphone to you
hi uh so I'm a founder of active kinetic
one uh we develop a new energy uh for
electricity and our question is
how are we going to power thousands of
people in space
um obviously there's no fossil fuels
um so what's the method that we've got
for interplanetary power
um incidentally we have actually got a
solution for that we think is quite good
but how would how would you guys do it
at this stage so to Martin just briefly
I mean how are we going to power a human
settlement on another planet yes
um well I mean I would guess with solar
energy and one thing which I'd add as a
footnote is that the idea of getting so
Lindsay in space and being down to earth
um it seemed crazy 30 years ago but with
the ability of the new SpaceX rocket to
launch 100 tons of stuff at a time and
robots to assemble it that's no longer
crazy I'm going to have to cut in there
we're coming to the end of our time
sorry we're against the clock uh being
live broadcast thank you very much
indeed everybody for joining us a panel
here experts giving us some sense of
excitement about the future of space
[Applause]